brought to you by PlayStation Plus with
new games monthly and next-gen
multiplayer on ps4 you and your friends
can experience more together another
month has come and gone and if you're a
budget minded gamer you know what that
means
sony has announced the latest wave of
free games coming to PlayStation Plus so
grab your wallets and throw them in the
trash we're about to find out what
you'll be paying zero dollars for in the
month of March the biggest title coming
to PlayStation Plus this month is tomb
raider on ps3 no not that one this one
last year's Tomb Raider reboot was an
absolute delight showcasing a younger
Lara Croft and her journey from a scared
kid to a one-woman wrecking ball if you
haven't played it yet you literally have
no excuse we're standing on a gold mine
if big-budget action games aren't your
thing you're in luck there's not one but
two offbeat indie gems free on
PlayStation 3 this month first up is
Thomas was alone a puzzle platformer
starring a cast of characters who are
far more charming and adorable than
rectangles have any right to be
and then there's lone survivor
director's cut also on PlayStation 3
this 2d survival horror game is less
about dealing with enemies than it is
about controlling your own mental
stability it's tense atmospheric and
features multiple endings for you to
chase after like so many shambling
zombies hey speaking of zombies here's
your ps4 game of the month it's dead
nation Apocalypse Edition this one is
pretty much the polar opposite of lone
survivor it's all about action and co-op
oh and zombies lots and lots of zombies
and finally there are two free games
coming to Vita unit 13 is a tactical
shooter that's been described by critics
as pretty ok and a game with guns in it
and then there's monster hunter freedom
unite which is technically a PSP game
but you can play it on your Vita and
have that same Monster Hunter experience
with all of its monsters and hunting and
all right I've never actually played a
monster hunter game but some people
really seem to like them and it's free
so hey want to give it a shot for more
on these games be sure to check out the
reviews on GameSpot calm